here's donald trump back in 2020 warning
gas prices will in fact be five six
seven dollars a gallon take a look
and gas prices you like that two dollar
gas right
how about five dollars six dollars and
seven dollars darling let's sell the car
it's a little bit too large let's get a
compact
biden's plan is an economic death
sentence
here there's a guy that knows a thing or
two about energy oil texas governor greg
abbott well i don't think the president
could have been any more right governor
he was spot on listen sean i'm coming to
you tonight from san patricio county
saint patricia county is on the gulf
coast right next to corpus chris corpus
christi
through this county runs a lot of
natural gas pipelines that connect to a
shanir lng facility president trump
worked to open up these lng facilities
to make sure that we would be able to
provide natural gas to countries like
germany or to the eu but also in
addition to that we have the ability to
move oil around because what you were
talking about about biden's closure
of pipelines because of shutting down
leases and things like that the ability
to drill that's one thing that's caused
the price of gasoline to go up so much
because the price of oil has gone up so
much biden knew when he was getting into
this situation with regard to russia and
the ukraine he knew that the price of
oil would be going up even more and so
everybody watching this show their the
price they're going to be paying at the
pump will be going up even more in the
coming days governor if biden would rely
upon an american-based energy we could
solve that problem governor rather than
importing you know 600 million barrels
of oil from opec and
and
five
million barrels from uh saudi arabia and
232 million barrels from from russia and
a million barrels of oil even from iran
how quickly could the oil industry get
up and running and producing and and
extracting the oil from the ground in
your view
very
under president trump under a president
who is committed uh to accelerating the
permitting process that could be done
extraordinarily quickly especially on
the pumping side because
many wells they're called drilled but
not completed wells and they could be up
and running very quickly so we could be
providing both the natural gas as well
as the oil not just to people across the
country but to people in other countries
such as in the european region
and i would believe the same thing is is
for natural gas as well and what about
transporting it to both nato and
european allies we could do that
a hundred percent uh through lng or
through uh ships that would get there so
again along the gulf coast here uh but
also in our neighborhood louisiana and
other parts of the country there are
many locations where we can ship both
oil and natural gas very easily what we
need is a president who's committed to
accelerating the permits not denying
permits under president trump we were
able to move very rapidly and became
energy independent under president biden
the price of gasoline and oil are going
up making america less affordable for
our fellow americans all right governor
great information we appreciate it as
always thank you for being with us hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else